what are your thoughts on crypto in
general
so would what what parts technically
or philosophically do you find
especially beautiful maybe oh i'm
extremely bullish on crypto long term
not any specific crypto project but this
idea
of well two ideas
one um the nakamoto consensus algorithm
is i think one of the greatest
innovations of the 21st century
this idea that people can reach
consensus you can reach a group
consensus
using a relatively straightforward
algorithm
is wild and
like you know satoshi nakamoto people
always ask me who i look up to it's like
whoever that is who do you think it is i
mean
elon musk is he is he you it is
definitely not me
and i do not think it's elon musk but
yeah this idea of uh groups reaching
consensus
in a decentralized yet formulaic way
is one extremely powerful idea from
crypto
um maybe the second idea
is this idea of smart contracts
when you write a contract uh between two
parties any contract
um this contract if there are disputes
it's interpreted by lawyers lawyers
are just really shitty overpaid
interpreters
imagine you had let's talk about them in
terms of a in terms of like let's
compare a lawyer to python
right so lawyer well okay that's really
oh i never thought of it that way it's
hilarious
so python i'm paying i'm paying um
you know even 10 cents an hour i'll use
the nice azure machine i can run python
for 10 cents an hour
lawyers cost a thousand dollars an hour
so python is is is
10 000 x uh better on that axis
um lawyers don't always return the same
answer
um python almost always does
uh cost
yeah i mean just just cost reliability
everything about python is so much
better than lawyers um so if you can
make smart contracts
this whole concept of code is law
i i love and i would love to live in a
world where everybody accepted that fact
so so maybe uh you can talk about what
smart contracts
are so let's say um
let's say you know we have a uh
even something as simple as a safety
deposit box
right safety deposit box that holds a
million dollars
i have a contract with the bank that
says two out of these three
parties uh must uh
be present to open the safety deposit
box and get the money out
so that's a contract for the bank and
it's only as good as the bank and the
lawyers right
let's say you know somebody dies and now
oh we're going to go through a big legal
dispute about whether oh well was it in
the will was it not in the well
what like it's just so messy and the
cost
to determine truth is so expensive
versus a smart contract which just uses
cryptography to check if two out of
three keys are present
well i can look at that and i can have
certainty
in the answer that it's going to return
and that's what all businesses want a
certainty
you know they say businesses don't care
viacom youtube youtube's like
look we don't care which way this
lawsuit goes just please tell us
so we can have certainty yeah i wonder
how many agreements in this world
because
we're talking about financial
transactions only
in this case correct the smart the smart
contracts oh you can go to you can go to
anything
you can go you could put a prenup in the
theater in blockchain
a married smart contract sorry divorce
lawyers
you're going to be replaced by python
uh okay so that's uh
so that's that's another beautiful idea
do you think
there's something that's appealing to
you about any one specific
implementation
so if you look 10 20 50 years down the
line
do you see any like bitcoin ethereum
any of the other hundreds of
cryptocurrencies winning out is there
like what's your intuition about the
space are you just sitting back and
watching the chaos and look who cares
what emerges
oh i don't i don't speculate i don't
really care i don't really care which
one of these projects wins
i'm kind of in the bitcoin as a meme
coin camp i mean why does bitcoin have
value it's technically kind of
you know what yeah not great like the
block
size debate when i found out what the
block size debate was i'm like
are you guys kidding what's the block
size debate
you know what it's really it's too
stupid to even talk about people
people people can look it up but i'm
like wow you know ethereum seems the
governance of ethereum seems much better
um i've come around i've been on proof
of stake ideas
uh you know very smart people thinking
about some things yeah
you know governance is interesting it
does feel like
uh vitalik it could just feel like an
open
in even in these distributed systems
leaders and
are helpful because they kind of help
you
drive the mission and the vision and
they put a face to a project
it's a weird thing about us humans
geniuses are helpful
like mattel right yeah brilliant
so you think the reason he's uh he's the
face
of a theorem is because he's a genius
that's interesting
i mean that was um
it's interesting to think about that we
need to create systems
in which uh the quote-unquote leaders
that emerge
are the geniuses in the system i mean
that's arguably why
the current state of democracy is broken
is the people who are
emerging as the leaders are not the most
competent are not the
superstars of the system and it seems
like at least for now
in the crypto world oftentimes the
leaders are the superstars
imagine at the debate they asked what's
the sixth amendment
what are the four fundamental forces in
the universe right what's the integral
of two to the x
yeah i'd love to see those questions
asked and that's what i want as our
leader
it's a little bit of a bayes rule
yeah i mean even oh wow you're hurting
my brain
that my standard was even lower but i
would have loved
to see just this basic
brilliance like i've talked to
historians there's just these
they're not even like they don't have a
phd or even an education history they
just uh
like a dan carlin type character who
just like
holy [ __ ] how did all this information
get into your head
they're able to just connect genghis
khan to
the entirety of the history of the 20th
century they they know
everything about every single battle
that happened
and they know the the the like
the game of thrones of the of the
different power plays and all that
happened there
and they know like the individuals and
all the documents involved
and it's and that they integrate that
into their regular life it's not like
they're
ultra history nerds they're just they
know this information
that's what competence looks like yeah
because i've seen that with programmers
too right that's what great programmers
do
but yeah it would be uh it's really
unfortunate that those kinds of people
aren't emerging as
as our leaders but for now at least in
the crypto world that seems to be the
case
i don't know if that always uh you could
imagine that in a hundred years that's
not the case right the crypto world has
one
very powerful idea going for it and
that's the idea of forks
right i mean
you know imagine uh
we'll use a less controversial example
um this was actually in my joke
uh app in 2012 i was like barack obama
mitt romney let's let him both be
president
right like imagine we could fork america
and just let him both be
president and then the americas could
compete and you know people could invest
in one
pull their liquidity out of one put it
in the other you have this in the crypto
world
ethereum forks into ethereum and
ethereum classic
and you can pull your liquidity out of
one and put it in another
and people vote with their dollars which
forks companies should be able to fork
i'd love to fork nvidia
you know yeah like different business
strategies
and yeah and then try them out and see
see what works
like even take uh
uh yeah take comm ai that closes its
source
and then take one that's open source and
see what works
take one that's purchased by gm and one
that remains
android renegade and all these different
versions and see the beauty of comma ai
is someone could actually do that
yeah please take home ai and fork it
that's right
that's the beauty of open source
you